[Music]
morning morning Hamburg first of all I'd
love to interact with you guys quite a
bit I'm pretty obsessed with QA so if
you guys want to roll I'm ready to go
there's a lot of different things I'd
like to talk about but the thing that I
probably want to most talk about is what
is up here which is when I come and
speak at conferences I'm always trying
to bring the most value that I can to
the audience and the thing that's
difficult when you speak at a conference
of this size is what's the makeup of the
audience are these founders or these
executives are they in digital marketing
are they b2b or they B to C are they
trying to build a personal brand there's
a lot of different things that everybody
in this room in this conference is
trying to accomplish so what I think is
a very good place to start is attention
I don't care what you do in this room I
don't care about what you're trying to
accomplish the key to all of it is
trading attention attention is the asset
before you tell me how great your b2b
SAS social media product is or how your
great your [ __ ] you're gonna t-shirt is
or how great your sneakers are or how
great you are as a tastemaker in bottled
water or fashion or yoga before anybody
in here gets to say what they're about
they need the end person's attention
attention is what we're all trading what
bothers old talk really was about was
attention once you have the attention
all the action starts and the way I
really think about this is a framework
of you know who you are how you're going
to talk about it and where you're going
to talk about it whw right like what are
you going to talk about so many of you
in this room have not started whether
you're talking about yourself or your
you've not started the process of
actually communicating what you're all
about what what is it what is your
manifesto what is your product bringing
to the table why should I give a [ __ ]
about what you're up to now the reality
is so many of you are at such an early
stage that manifesto should actually
just be your mission right you haven't
done anything yet
you know this whole fake it to you make
it brings no value to anybody you need
to tell me what you're gonna do which is
very scary because you actually have to
execute on the next part that so many of
you have to think about is how I'm very
concerned that most people feel that
whatever the current thing is is what
you have to do so as many of you know
video is massively over-indexing in the
game right now
Facebook video YouTube crushing it but
there are so many people in here that
shouldn't be producing video because
that is not the best way they
communicate only a decade ago as I was
speaking here all I would be talking
about is blogging which was one of the
few platforms that I never got involved
with in the last 20 years because even
though I've written for New York Times
bestselling books I can't write for [ __ ]
right I can't put three sentences
together that make any sense if I didn't
have a ghostwriter I would have zero
books yet there are people in this room
that are caught up by picture and video
communication and they are tremendous
writers and they don't realize that
blogging or posting on medium or even my
favorite little hack right now if you're
a good writer and you want to build up a
profile for your business or for
yourself
I actually highly recommend you start
blogging inside of Facebook and
Instagram I literally mean writing seven
fifteen twenty five sentences three four
or five paragraphs were written content
within your feeds that people will
absolutely consume see the reason I know
that is another theme that before I get
into the last W of where the reason I
say that is because the other thing that
I wanted to speak about this morning is
something that really matters to me
which is the following we are living
through
and this room is filled with them and
the whole world is filled with them we
are living through the greatest era of
headline readers the amount of people in
this audience who have their own ideas
about Facebook Instagram snapchat
blogging podcasting SEO SEM programmatic
whatever maybe the amount of people here
that have strong opinions on the ROI of
these things yet they've never executed
and single ad on snapchat or executed
more than three or four campaigns on
these platforms is startling to me I am
stunned by the lack of practitioner ship
in our space you have so many people
pontificating about what's going on yet
they've never done anything there are
people rolling around with Amazon Alexa
voice skills points of view and they
don't have an echo in their home they've
never written a skill they have no idea
they've read a Business Insider article
they were at a TechCrunch post they've
read something once their best friend is
good at technology and said something
that they now parrot but we are living
through ungodly amounts of people who
read a couple of headlines and have a
point of view and just roll a lot of
people that congratulated me yesterday
because I was an early investor in
snapchat that don't realize that I have
to wait six months before I get to sell
my stock and who gives a [ __ ] about what
it does on day one I saw five months of
30 days before anything actually happens
is interesting to me it was an
interesting I was I got 33,000
congratulations and I replied not yet
not yet not yet we're living in a world
politically we're living in a world
socially and we are definitely living in
a business world practically that is
absolutely not in the trenches the best
way I articulated is the following we
have a whole lot of people that want to
be architects and we have very few
plumbers and Masons in our industry and
so what does that mean why am i
fascinated by that it speaks to the last
of the whw once you know what you're
going to say your manifest
so you're promised your words your
mission of the product once you know how
you're going to say it and that matters
video audio written word they all work
podcasting re-emerge in the last three
years after the voice wasn't winning
video clearly dominating written word
still very strong way too many people
here disrespecting it but the next part
is where how do you get people to
actually know what the hell you're up to
what you're about what your product or
service is up to especially when you
have no audience I love when people say
Gary it's easy for you now you have a
million followers plus on all these
platforms great Rick I had zero ten
years ago [ __ ]
I worked right and so what I want to
remind everybody is in 2007 when I had
zero audience I spent 12 hours a day on
the where part and that part at the time
was using a site called summize comm
which was later Twitter search and I
searched every single person that
mentioned the word whine and I replied
to them and that was my hand-to-hand
combat of arbitrage today every single
person here has a product and service a
mission something that brought them here
today everybody wants the world or a
certain part of the world to know what
they're up to and there's incredible
ways to get that awareness around what
you're doing for example it is stunning
to me how many people want to build
their Instagram audience and they don't
do the two core things that build an
Instagram audience number one they don't
use 10 15 or 20 hashtags to be
discovered because that's the plumbing
of that ecosystem number two they don't
spend two to three hours a day direct
messaging until Instagram stops them all
the individuals that have the awareness
that they aspire for and ask them for
awareness for what they're doing by
offering that person something in return
you're not going to DM somebody who has
eight hundred thirty seven thousand
followers on Instagram and they're just
going to post your picture you need to
pay attention to what they care about
DM them with something that matters to
them and return hope that they'll give
you awareness and you need to do it for
two or three hours a day because one
ninety-seven one out of every 336 is
actually going to do it for you but
here's one way I promise you that you
will not build your Instagram profile by
not doing anything by sitting and having
a beer with your friend and complaining
that it's so hard to build your profile
actually you know what can I spend a
second on complaining come here can I
spend a second on complaining you want
to do this with me let's talk about
complaining there are only two people
two groups of people that will actually
listen to your complaining are we doing
a selfie two groups Thanks one the four
to five people that love you the most
your mother your spouse the people that
have to the other group of people that
will listen to your complaining are your
other loser friends can we yeah that's
actually actually I'm done thank you I'm
glad some people clapping this because I
am blown away by the people that are
trying to aspire you know I'm fascinated
by how many of you and when I say you I
don't mean this room I mean [ __ ] in the
world how many of you have your mouth
your ambitions the things you say you're
going to do so far ahead of your actions
so many people telling me that they're
going to build ten fifty hundred two
hundred million dollar companies and
they're scared to work 12 hours a day
we are not catching up in our action to
our ambitions and what it leads to is a
whole lot of complaining of course it's
supposed to be hard
people Gary it's so hard no [ __ ] [ __ ]
you want to make millions of dollars and
live your perfect life why should that
be easy makes no sense
do you know that most people in this
room with their ambitions for their
startups or careers are actually
projecting to a one-percent life
you know how that math actually works
out we are completely disconnected from
reality
and and as a lot of people in here that
maybe have a couple of gray hairs or
losing their hair like I am know we've
lived through a very good global
economic period over the last seven or
eight years I want to remind everybody
here who's been in tech for twenty years
about the late 90s early 2000s and 2007
and eight my friends if I can leave this
trip to Germany with one thing I'm going
to leave you with this please and I mean
please forget about the inspiration and
the awesome [ __ ] DJ and the good
speakers forget all that I'm asking you
to do one thing for me
please get practical please get
practical let me tell you why if you
wanna start up in this room and you're
losing money each month because you
raise capital
you're in deep [ __ ] [ __ ] let me
explain why it doesn't take a hero or a
successful entrepreneur to lose money
each month and when inevitably whether
it's tomorrow morning or 24 months from
now but I sure know when we go to seven
or eight years of economic growth we're
just a few minutes away again I don't
know if it's tomorrow I don't know if
it's four years from now but it just
can't go another seven that when that
money drives up when that money is gone
you actually have to make money over the
two cycles of tech innovation and this
space that I've been in what happens is
everybody here goes from saying
entrepreneur and founder into their
Instagram to working at Bank of America
or GE it is right now let's do a call to
arms let's use this remarkable event to
not only get inspired and rah-rah and
cheer ourselves up in our [ __ ]
ecosystem let's use today for everybody
to look in the mirror and ask themselves
if they're being practical about what
they're doing because it can't go great
forever
and the best way to survive it is to be
practical
how many people have a start-up or an
entrepreneur running their own business
raise your hands i or you to get very
serious about what i'm talking about for
the rest of you and the rest of us it is
time to trade attention we are living
through the greatest era of business
ever it is remarkable that this has
become the remote control of our lives
there's nothing nothing more important
than this when I hear the word social
media I know so many people think of
that as a sprinkle as an afterthought as
an emerging kind of thing to me it is
every minute of what people spend on
this device outside of utilities and
games it is the foundation it is the
foundation of our society this is the
remote control of our lives and over 50
percent of our time is spent on one of
these seven or eight social networks to
me the term social media is the slang
term for the current state of the
internet and I implore you and I promise
you that if your strategy around
communicating on those seven eight-nine
websites that matter is not the first
thing on your mind you will have zero
relevancy over the next decade and most
importantly and this matters what scares
me quite a bit is that most of you when
you see these logos you think of a piece
of content that you make and you think
of those five channels and more as
places where you distribute it these are
not just distribution channels these are
channels where you have to natively
story tell in the context of the
platform the videos that work on YouTube
versus Facebook are different you don't
take the same video and just post it for
distribution the picture on Instagram
and Facebook is different you were
disrespecting the psychology of the user
even if it's a fad do right there with
the white hat and the hustle mow t-shirt
when he's on Instagram and he's on
Facebook he's a different dude his
mindsets different he follows different
people he's on those channels for
different reasons it is imperative that
not
only do you start thinking about your
content strategy on these platforms for
your business how many people here on
the b2b business b2b hire perfect b2b
friends you are disrespecting how much
b2b business is happening here facebook
allows you to target the employees of
customers you can make a three-minute
video that says does the CFO of your
company know and then send it to all the
employees of and then all of a sudden
that CFO is getting 50 60 emails from
employees of his or her company making
them aware of your SAS product for the
CFO this is what I'm talking about about
headline readers versus practitioners
headline readers don't think that b2b is
happening here practitioners are
exploiting it and making real money
headline readers think that you have to
make short videos on social media
practitioners are making 20 30 40 minute
videos telling their story compelling
people into their world
read marketing to the people that
actually why on it and close it and
close those sales by remarketing if
somebody watched 37 minutes of your
video about you or your business when
you remarked it that view was a call to
action you don't think you're going to
convert them my friends we are looking
we're living through this incredible era
of massive opportunity yet everybody is
talking and reading and nobody's [ __ ]
doing
start [ __ ] executing don't read about
how to win on snapchat download the
[ __ ] app and do something dick face
slice I try I don't know you fix at all
but I promise you this you're not
sitting there because you heard or
pondered or thought about it you [ __ ]
execute it somehow right yeah I mean you
don't think it'd be really [ __ ] rad
to throw a conference you [ __ ] did it
you didn't dream about [ __ ] spinning
you [ __ ] practice not a better
your grandparents my grandparents they
had a [ __ ] compared to us we have the
Internet I don't have you heard about it
it's really [ __ ] good and what it
does is it allows us to be practical
about having a much better life if we
choose to put in the work you can
actually work your nine-to-five pay your
bills come home have a beer and then
start working on what you want because
the infrastructure exists your
grandparents had to have their job they
couldn't open their other business
because it was at night and you like
this is a remarkable era to be around
and yet we are completely wasting it let
me actually throw you for a complete
curveball you know what you all need to
do you only need to go and and volunteer
at a senior citizen home if you want to
do one thing if anything besides being
practical and start making money instead
of losing money is what you remember
from this talk this morning please make
it that you need to go to a senior
citizen home and volunteer for one day
here's what I want you to do spend one
day at a senior citizen home and I
promise you you will leave with the
following you will leave that the
scariest thing in the world the scariest
thing in the world to human beings is
regret what you will see and those 80
and 90 year olds some will be happy and
they'll be content but you will see
something at scale that scares the
living [ __ ] out of me it's called regret
the amount of people that wish they did
things is scary and let me promise you
something when you're 93 it's hard to
pull it off we are so fortunate we live
in a hero right now where mainstream
media in every part of the world is
pumping down nothing but negativity yet
every piece of data shows you that this
is the greatest era to ever be alive and
I understand we have problems we all
have massive problems but they're not as
bad as they used to be as bad as brexit
or Trump or terrorism or as bad as
anything you think is depending on your
points of view it's better than the
black [ __ ] plague
we have to put things into context and
if you're fortunate enough to be here
today to know to be here today to afford
to be here today you are sitting in an
incredible spot of the seven point seven
billion people on earth and I just don't
understand why you wouldn't take full
advantage of it and it starts with
something very basic which is actually
start understanding how this is all
working deeper not wider you don't need
to know in theory how a I and Alexa Boys
and B are and social media work you need
to start understanding how one of those
things works deeply I've gotten here
today because I didn't come to
conferences and talk or make videos or
build a personal brand for the first 15
years of my career let me remind many of
you long before I was Gary Vee I was
Gary Vaynerchuk building a liquor store
by being good at email marketing at
Google AdWords at banner retargeting at
YouTube marketing I was a [ __ ]
practitioner and then once I built
something from 0 to 60 milli to 60
million with no money once I built
something then I had a little audacity
to come and talk to you about how I did
it the amount of 23 year old business
coaches and marketing gurus who haven't
done dick [ __ ] and their [ __ ] life
that's out there on Instagram right now
is startling it is time to do and less
talking and more [ __ ] doing right
yeah excited you you agree right random
[ __ ] it's the gram influencers Instagram
influencers right now today for doers is
the probably by only behind Facebook ads
the single best arbitrage in marketing
the fact that you can reach out to
people that have three hundred three
thousand thirty thousand three hundred
thousand and three million followers and
trade with them for exposure for your
product and service is remarkable
especially because 80 percent of them
don't know how to price themselves and
there
underpriced 10% of them are so
overpriced because they think they're
followers of a lot of followers means
that they're valuable so you have to be
careful the top-end but when you start
getting into that 30,000 to 400,000
followed people the remarkable value of
just giving them the product or giving
them a hundred bucks to give a shot on
the product so many people's businesses
and careers would be in a much greater
place today if they spent 3 to 5 hours a
day DMing Instagram influencers and
business developing with them and
building exposure for their brand yet
most of you will hear this you'll be
like yeah you might do it for a day I
said 3 to 5 bucket hours you know you
may do it for a day you may do it for a
week you may not do it at all and then
in four years from now you'll look back
and regret it how many people have been
doing digital marketing or business in
the internet world for 15 years or more
just raise your hands just cured high
please raise it high just curious a lot
of you who raised her hands know that if
I was giving this speech when I was
building Wine Library in 2001 and I was
talking about Google AdWords and they
were 5 and 10 cents a click a lot of you
with your mindset would still be trying
to figure out what the ROI of that was
why direct mail was better or newspapers
were better that most people weren't on
search yet and why would people go to
Google Yahoo was the leader like that's
what you would debate yet we all sit
here 10 15 years later regretting that
we didn't spend all our money on Google
AdWords because the arbitrage was
unbelievably phenomenally under priced I
will make I'm saying this now not for
the 5,000 of you I'm saying what I'm
about to say for myself because I'm
selfish because d-roc somewhere here and
I'm going to use the cliff for myself in
five years to prove to everybody that I
was right as we sit here today if you
are not spending the majority of your
money on your marketing on Facebook ads
on Instagram influencers you are making
a massive mistake in 36 to 48 months all
of you will be spending
three four five six ten fifteen times
more money to achieve the same goal that
can be achieved today so I implore you
if you do not know how to do Facebook
advertising at scale if you do not know
what's going on in the influencer
marketing specifically on Instagram
YouTube and snapchat as well that
there's an incredible website that you
can go to that will help you figure out
every little detail of what I can't get
to in here over the next five minutes so
I know some of you like to write down
sites I see some of you pulling out I'll
spell it for you gee oh oh gee oh yeah
you like that one that's good right I
don't know one yeah I mean it's
remarkable to me how many people ask me
well Gary how do I do that
zip code or that employees of Facebook
ad you Google how do I run Facebook ads
against employees of companies enter six
hundred [ __ ] thousand results on how
to do it
practitioner ship I've been in this game
for twenty years right now and I promise
you from the day I met Bob ten years ago
it is very simple ninety-nine percent of
people talk pontificate read and think
and 1 percent do the more you can push
yourself to do the more you can take
risks the fact that not every person in
the world wakes up every morning
Opel's opens their Apple or Google phone
looks at the top 100 apps on either one
of those platforms and then downloads
any app that they're not aware of
whether that's Marco Polo or anchor
musically or house-party today or
snapchat and Instagram three or four
years ago blows my mind you will always
know what's coming by just looking at
the data people you say to me you're
always so right you're you're like
people like you're like you know how do
you know the future I'm like listen I'm
not Nostradamus this is very simple I do
the work I wake up in the morning I open
my Apple phone I go to the App Store app
I go to top 150 free apps in the world I
go to
the bottom first and anything I've never
seen before that's hit the top 150 I
click it to read if it's a social
network I download it I taste it yes I
do understand consumer behavior maybe a
little bit better than most but I would
have never gotten there if I didn't
download it read it use it and put in
the work and what I know is for every
plurk for every social cam for every
vine for every Marco Polo or other
things that doesn't make it all you have
to do is go 1 out of 50 for it all to be
worth it I'm willing to put in the work
I'm willing to be a practitioner I'm
willing to be practical I think about
the whw that what the hell am I going to
say how am I going to say it and where
I'm going to say it and I do it over and
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over and over and I will do it for the
rest of my life I will become a
billionaire I will buy the New York Jets
and I will win Super Bowls thank you
you